[Musique]
voir les enfants lever la main qui n'a
pas été sage aujourd'hui mois où nous
nous nous pour moi oh je sais tu deviens
nounours terrible ne pense plus qu'à
t'amuser ce vrai patron mais je vais
encore m'amuser avec mes petits amis
et aux homos propre ou bobo aux bonis
falla gens portant un gros bonnet de
laine porte patronales en porte alors
une chers amis où sont ils allés
en t'attendant pour jouer non pour
quelque chose de sérieux pour téléphoner
à cornichons pourri mais dire qu'on a la
permission d'aller en vacances chez lui
juste pour quelques sous mais voilà une
nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui si au bout rond
voyons
et 2
ici le centre de renseignements monsieur
pour téléphoner à la roulotte de
cornichons s'il vous plaît
puis la numéro de son département
merci mademoiselle
handidanse et facile aux rien de plus
simple vous allez voir la
[Musique]
samo mais c'est pas la musique de
cornichons c'est exact mais on approche
attention
là
ça y est la commission salue
ça fait plaisir de vous entendre des
12es à la maison
autant les potes c'est la voix vous
venez bientôt oui on vient de voir
wojcicki alors ce qu'on veut s'amuser
alors et moi attendez dada de vous
parler allons allons
allons chers amis je piaffe d'impatience
de vous voir à bien tous chers tata au
revoir cornichons au revoir on vous
attend
nato qui repose sur le fil au
au revoir oui
on a coupé 6 juillet pas elle jouait
avec les filles nous nous sommes dit
tout ce que nous avions à nous dire aux
l'ont
fait les enfants exemple
bonne nuit mais cher petit la gt fatigue
pas la jeter la lumière
faites de beaux rêves mes petits l'on
n'y prenait cette brève petit frère
[Musique]
et
ollon nounours dépêche toi en route
chers patrons or ce qu'ils sont gentils
mon petit ami bonn les enfants allez
vite vous couchez aussi sagement que
nicolas et pimprenelle n'oubliez pas de
faire votre toilette de bien vous l'a vu
les temps embrasser bien fort vos
parents est fait pour eux
[Musique]
oh